european defence policy will be a
highlight as EU leaders meet in Brussels
this week looking to bolster the union's
military capabilities and boost the
defense industry the council where
defense is being discussed for the first
time in five years will urge countries
to deepened defense cooperation and
improve Europe's capacity to conduct
operations abroad the aim is to increase
the effectiveness and visibility of
security and defence policy and
strengthen the defense industry while
developing more efficient military
capabilities the industry totals some
400,000 jobs and creates almost a
million more in other areas helping to
increase competitiveness is likely to
boost employment further as well as
economic growth turning to the economy
the leaders are likely to call for
economic policies to be better
coordinated to encourage higher levels
of sustainable growth and help detect
vulnerabilities at an early stage
they're expected to underline the need
to advance reforms in areas central to
encouraging growth and job creation the
talks could also turn to the banking
Union and ambitious new safety mechanism
to ensure that EU member states will be
able to weather the financial crises of
the future in international affairs the
leaders will also discuss developments
in Ukraine following the government's
decision to postpone signing a major
agreement on closer ties and a trade
pact thousands of people have been
protesting daily in Kiev since the
decision last month the council will
also address the issue of illegal
immigration and particularly the plight
of would-be asylum seekers crossing the
Mediterranean in poorly maintained boats